THEIR CITIZENSHIP IN PROTEST
OVER THE WAR.
MATTHEW CHANCE IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: ONE OF THE MOST
HIGH PROFILE RICHEST RUSSIANS TO
PUBLICLY CONDEMN THE UKRAINE
WAR.
HE'S THE BILLIONAIRE WHO FOUNDED
THE TINKOF BANK, NOW RENOUNCING
HIS RUSSIAN CITIZENSHIP, A IMAGE
SLAP TO THE KREMLIN'S FACE.
HE EVEN HOSTED THE DETERMINATION
DOCUMENT ONLINE.
"I CAN'T AND WON'T BE ASSOCIATED
WITH A FASCIST COMPANY," HE
WROTE ON INSTAGRAM.
A COUNTRY THAT STARTED A WAR
WITH THEIR PEACEFUL MATES.
HE CALLED ON OTHER WEALTHY
RUSSIANS TO ALSO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY BEHIND.
"I HOPE MORE PROMINENT RUSSIAN
BUSINESS MEN WILL FOLLOW ME SO
IT WEAKENS PUTIN'S REGIME AND
HIS ECONOMY AND PUTS HIM
EVENTUALLY TOWARDS DEFEAT."
THE POST WAS QUICKLY DELETED
WHICH HE BLAMES ON KREMLIN
TROLLS.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME TINKOF
HAS PUBLICLY CRITICIZED PUTIN.
THESE ALMOST DAILY SCENES OF
VIOLENCE AND ITS HORRORS SEEM TO
HAVE GALVANIZED THE BILLIONAIRE.
BACK IN MAY SPOKE OF HOW HIS OWN
FIGHT FOR SURVIVAL, SUFFERING
FROM CANCER, MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO STAY SILENT.
>> Translator: YOU SEE KIDS,
WOMEN, PEOPLE DYING FOR NOTHING,
BEING MURDERED BY SOMEONE.
THE RUSSIAN ARMY IS KILLING THEM
FOR NOTHING.
YOU CAN DIE FROM CANCER.
WHY SHOULD YOU DIE FROM A BOMB
JUST BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN
UKRAINE?
THIS IS MESSED UP, ESPECIALLY IN
THE 21st CENTURY.
>> Reporter: OF COURSE THERE
HAVE BEEN OTHER PROMINENT
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRES WHO
CRITICIZED THE UKRAINE WAR, EVEN
THE METALS MAGNATE LEARNED TO BE
CLOSE TO PUTIN CALLING IT A
COLOSSAL MISTAKE.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, ANOTHER
BILLIONAIRE INVESTOR SAID HE
RENOUNCED HIS RUSSIAN PASSPORT
TOO.
TINKOF SEEN IN LONDON WHERE
DESPITE BRITISH SANCTIONS HE
STILL SPENDS MUCH OF HIS TIME
SAID HE ONLY EVER MET PUTIN ONCE
FOR A BEER MORE THAN 20 YEARS
AGO.
HE SAYS HE HATES PUTIN'S RUSSIA
AND IS SEVERING HIMSELF FROM IT
ALTOGETHER OVER WHAT HE CALLS
PUTIN'S CRAZY WAR.
>> SO, MATTHEW, DOES HIS
RENOUNCE YAGS MEAN PUTIN IS
LOSING SUPPORT AMONG RUSSIAN
BUSINESS TYCOONS?
AFTER EVERYTHING WE'VE SEEN,
HE'S CHOOSING TO DO THIS NOW.
>> Reporter: IT'S GOT A POINT IN
THAT DIRECTION.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER TINKOF IS A
UNIQUE CASE.
HE SOLD HIS BUSINESSES IN
RUSSIA.
HE'S GOT LEUKEMIA.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER BUSINESS
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY THAT HAVE
A LOT TO LOSE.
SPEAKING OUT LIKE THAT WOULD
MEAN THE END OF YOUR BUSINESS.
IT COULD MEAN JAIL OR DANGER FOR
YOUR FAMILY.
EVEN IF THEY AGREE WITH HIM,
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO KEEP
THEIR MOUTHS SHUT.
THE FACT THAT ANYONE IS SPEAKING
OUT AT ALL, AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL HIGH PROFILE-BUSINESS
PEOPLE, IT CAN AFFECT THE
ECONOMY IN RUSSIA.
>> CIRCUMSTANCES ARE SPECIFIC TO
HIM.
IT'S STILL A COURAGEOUS ACT.
MATTHEW CHANCE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THE CONTEXT HERE IS THAT YOU
HAVE THIS DISARRAY AMONG RUSSIA
TROOPS AND THE LEADER OF THE
BRUTAL PRIVATE ARMY IS GAINING
INFLUENCE EVERY DAY.
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST WHO SPECIALIZES THE
RUSSIA SERVICES, THE AUTHOR OF
"THE COMPATRIOTS."
YOU KNOW SO MUCH ABOUT TINKOF
AND PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
PRIGOZHIN IS URGING RUSSIA TO
SHUT DOWN YOUTUBE.
WHEN YOU'RE COMING OUT AND
YOU'RE A MEMBER OF A MERCENARY
GROUP TALKING ABOUT YOUTUBE,
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE?
WHY IS HE BECOMING SO MUCH MORE
EMBOLDENED?
>> WELL, HE'S EXTREMELY
AMBITIOUS.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S GETTING
AMBITIOUS POLITICALLY.
HE FOUND THE WEAK SPOT THE
KREMLIN HAS.
TWO WEEKS AGO IT WAS ABOUT THE
MILITARY.
HE CRITICIZED THE MILITARY
OPENLY.
HE GOT SOME CHANGES.
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND IN THE
MILITARY WAS CHANGED.
THEY'VE GOT A NEW COMMANDER.
NOW HE'S IDENTIFYING THAT THE
KREMLIN IS LOSING INFORMATION
CONTROL ON THE INTERNET.
YOUTUBE IS ONE OF THE SERVICES
WHICH IS STILL NOT BLOCKED IN
THE COUNTRY, AVAILABLE FOR THE
RUSSIANS AND USED WIDELY FOR
WATCHING THE NEWS ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
NOW HE'S ATTACKING THIS WEAK
SPOT TO MAKE HIMSELF VISIBLE AND
USEFUL FOR PUTIN.
>> WHEN YOU SAY VISIBLE AND
USEFUL FOR PUTIN, HE YESTERDAY
SAID THE CHILDREN OF RUSSIA'S
ELITE SHOULD BE MOBILIZED.
HE CONFRONTED PUTIN OVER THE
WAR, TO TELL PUTIN TO UP THE
ANTE.
HE ALSO THE OTHER DAY PRAISED
ZELENSKYY'S LEADERSHIP SAYING HE
SHOULD NOT BE UNDERESTIMATED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HIS GOALS ARE?
DOES HE WANT TO RUN RUSSIA'S
MILITARY?
HOW DOES THIS COMBINATION OF
THINGS HE'S DOING ENDEAR HIM TO
PUTIN?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S NOT
STUPID.
HE UNDERSTANDS HIS LIMITS.
HE NEVER HAD ANY MILITARY
TRAINING.
HE SPENT TIME IN -- HE RUNS THIS
MILITARY COMPANY.
I DON'T THINK HIS AMBITION IS TO
BECOME MINISTER OF DEFENSE, BUT
MAYBE ON T